the first thing Marielle does is reset
their lives to the night Sam have the
idea that will destroy the world they
are at Chianti's on West fourth a small
table near the back he told her that
their conversation during the date
planted the seed of his experiment so
here she is to uproot it I think we
should move in together
Sam nearly spits out his wine it's a
dramatic way to derail his train of
thought they've only been dating for six
weeks in their previous life it took
nearly three years to reach this point
after the mess her parents had made all
romantic relationships seemed
provisional Sam is a committer though
eyes lit you're not pulling my chain no
chain she says no strings it buys her
eight months an apartment on Maple
Street two toothbrushes in the cup she
almost forgets the life they'd already
lived then one evening she comes home
late and he's at the kitchen table
surrounded by familiar looking diagrams
the floor drops out from under her you
had an idea
Muriel says I totally had an idea wait
till I tell you before you do can you
remember when you had it Sam and Andy
Wang carpool
when Marielle has to stay late at the
supercomputing Center where they all
work and of course they've been talking
about how to prove the simulation
hypothesis
she resets a day and drives Sam home
instead not enough the conversation has
been ongoing
she tries a week a month still the
diagrams on the table laying out a path
to the end of everything
she finally resets to before the carpool
began and creates a convincing paper
trail that suggests Andy Wong like
terribly on his CV she sends it
anonymously to the head of research sam
carpools with Kristen cants the office
manager they share an interest in police
dramas they do not discuss computational
physics two years pass their
relationship is different this time Mary
L finds she's more thoughtful more open
she experiences things more deeply the
smell of food the taste of salt on Sam's
skin after he's been running she Nadja's
him away from investigating the granular
structure of space-time then he puts in
a request for super computer access as
part of his personal project allocation
we can do it in software
he says bubbling over she feels like
she's falling again how can you test if
we're living in a simulation using
software maybe it will be a blind alley
but he has a brilliant idea about using
nested simulations to predict the
operating constraints of the machine the
universe could be running on two
brilliant
Marielle resets and proposes three years
ahead of schedule
they honeymoon in Europe while on a
tourist visit to CERN he gets a look on
his face I just had a crazy thought
about the simulation hypothesis he's
hardly finished the sentence before she
resets to four months earlier and
convinces him to choose Thailand she
enjoys a second round of dress fittings
and reception planning
two years more she holds it together
they had been childless in their other
life but this time there's Elle and
everything is so different
one night they've been up for hours
finally they're colicky girl is asleep
they sit on the floor of the nursery
toys strewn around them leg lifts with
fatigue
whoa Sam says I just had the wildest
idea know Muriel snaps at him you do not
have any ideas you hear me no ideas no
experiments she's shaking she can't
reset again the past never happens the
same way twice
nature will roll the dice and give her a
different child and L will be gone
forever it's just colic he says it'll
get better not if you keep going it
won't
so she tells him what happened when he
proved they were living inside a
simulation the bargain she made to
prevent the beings who run the universe
from wiping it clean afterwards there is
a strange brightness in his eyes that
she mistakes for fear for grief seven
years later
Ella's at school Marielle is home ill
she uses Sam's computer to catch up on
work and as she does his email window
pops up
it's an acceptance for his paper on the
simulation hypothesis the editor of the
journal is effusive he commends Sam for
the years of work he'd put in years
Muriel puts her head on the table she
sobs and sobs
she is suddenly in a grey room I can do
it I can she says I managed for 12 years
do you know how many times I reset too
many times the voice is as colorless as
the room you could not prevent this
knowledge from spreading as he promised
her wipe is required wait
she says desperate l will need picking
up from school soon or is the universe
frozen when she's in the gray room
paused while a finger hovers over the
delete button wait there's still
something she resets to mid pregnancy
when she and Sam were hiking an autumn
Sunday finds them at the top of Grouse
Mountain Mary L lags behind tells him
it's the weight of the baby that slows
her down rather than dread they walk a
narrow path even knowing what she knows
it's hard to believe everything is code
L growing inside her the Sun in the blue
sky her husband
Sam stands on the cliff edge admiring
the view she is so close to him now she
steps forward